okay
can you hear me
[Music]
well again thank you roderick and
sandrine for invitation to be here it's
really it's really great
so i will be talking about loan rates
and how we are using them to develop
this idea of the functional isotopics
analysis and i will talk a lot about
quality of long reads but also a little
bit of biology
of course i mean i don't have to explain
you why alternative splicing is
important
you may have from watching the
possibility of encoding different
proteins and it has been claimed that
this is
a source of organism complexity is
important for the cell differentiation
is also relevant to disease
and of course
ali also mentioned what was the problem
with the with the short reach to resolve
the uh
iso form complexity again i don't have
to explain this and also i don't have to
explain a lot why the long reach
technologies are helping us to
resolve these ambiguities of the long
range and this is basically an example
of the annotation for a particular genes
the idols transcription factor that you
have an encode and these are the
set of long reads in the human uh h1 zen
line and then you can kind of
see that we have completed you know
external structures here you could try
to compare them to see which one
corresponds
to each
of the annotations we know that they are
novelty for example this read here will
include these two actions that are not
found in the reference or for example we
have here another
read
that is providing a different
subscription start site
but actually actually what i am
interested in is understanding the
biological implications about this
because we know that when you have
different isoforms you may have
functional changes like for example you
may have that you are losing an active
site that is involved in a catalytic
domain of you may change the ability of
a transcription factor to bind to the
dna
uh
protein protein binding may be affected
by the loss of a binding domain in the
isoform
nuclear localization is very important
so nuclear catalyzation signals are
encoded and different in different
isoforms if of course we have also the
utrs that we may have different
inclusion of regulatory elements that
have to do with the stability of the
isoforms and actually i was quite
interested in
working on this when i started to look
at long reads for the analysis of the
transcriptome with the idea of
developing these
functional isotrosium analysis
pipeline
for that we have been developing a
number of tools and one of them is
scanty that
became
an important tool for the analysis of
the quality of the uh of this data and i
will you i will explain you exactly what
the scandal is doing why is important
but other things that we are doing is
trying to annotate different uh
transcript structures isoforms of future
device forms with a large diversity of
functional elements so that we can uh
predict what will happen when we have a
different isoforms and finally we have
developed also the tapas tool that is
strength is trying to use this
information to do actually a statistical
analysis of differential iso from
expression and what are the functional
consequences of that
so about the scanty ali also introduced
skeletal categories was one of the major
contributions of this work
and basically what we were trying to do
here was to understand what was the
complexity that we were seeing with the
long-range technologies so the idea is
that when you
have your long-range results and you
have inferred the transcript that are
represented by the long reads
you can compare this with the reference
and then indicate whether this is a
reference match pretty much what you
have in the reference full displaced
match with the same uh
junction chains but not taking care of
the ends the completes are missing some
uh junctions at the beginning of the end
and the novel in cadillac and the normal
ah not in catalogue sorry music here and
then uh represent the novelty of a noun
genes and then you have some other
things like genetic genomic and the same
fusion that
describes the the further this
complexity
okay so that was the definition that we
propose and has been very much accepted
by the community
but actually scandi what he's doing is
trying to characterize uh these
different type of iso forms with with
additional data
so what is its county measuring
so uh if we compare to the reference the
things that we are looking at is that
the distance that we have from the tss
and the tts to the matching reference of
the matching gene and what is this
difference we are also uh looking if we
have additional orthogonal data which is
support that we have like cage of
whether we have uh poliasites or uh
polya
of any kind of data that supports the
poly the side
we also if we have matching of related
illumina data we can also look at the
coverage of the junctions by the shore
reads we do something that is called the
ratio tss
metric that basically we are measuring
which is the ratio of uh shore reads and
the tss of the predicted electronic
model we calculate the refraction of
each transcript to relate to the total
expression of the gene we look whether
we have evidence of artistic chain poly
interpreting all kind of different
things we are measuring up to five
different type of properties we are
collecting here and we hope that we can
use this to identify which are
good transcripts and which are kind of
more noisy uh predictions
at the end scandi is producing a kind of
very broad report in which all this
information is plotted usually by a
scanty category so that you can
understand how they behave
with all these type of data
and actually this has been very useful
to see
what different analysis pipeline have
been doing with the same type of data
and i'm not we will hear the names of
the pipelines not to be any enemies but
basically on the same data if you look
at different type of analysis pipeline
you can see that the distribution of the
scantic categories can be very different
so this one is detecting a lot of
incompletes while this one is predicting
a lot of novel nodding catalogs and then
some others that have a huge capacity
for uh identifying energetic uh
transcripts right
so actually this is a kind of a
motivation why we finally
what we uh decided to participate in the
longer gas project that was uh
invitation by also by roderick and ali
um
kind of three years back
in which we were trying to see okay so
how do we assess and the uh accuracy of
uh different
with sequencing platforms and and
methods uh to infer transcriptomes and
we have different species we sequence
there with different uh platforms also
with illumina
nanopore of course we have different
samples but also different library
protocols the regular cdna but also
direct rna and r2c2 for nanopore and
then the trap that is trying to capture
the uh
uh the fibrinogens
um just suggest a few uh ideas of a few
of the results of
these
analysis one of the things that we are
seeing is that actually the number of
detected transcripts is very different
across different uh
pipelines of our different tools um and
you can have actually like
uh on the same sample very very
different uh resolutions per uh analysis
pipeline but actually what is kind of
more interesting to see is that if we
look at the standard deviation the
number of chains of transcripts
that are detected
considering the same tool the same
sequencing platform on the same library
prep so data tends to agree more
according to the tool so the algorithm
that is analyzing the data that actually
the analysis pipeline of the library
preparation so there is a very strong
component on the algorithm in the
identification of which are the
transcripts that are being expressed
this is for gene this is for transcript
here is not as strong but still the the
analysis pipeline is having a very
strong impact
in the result
this is uh what you get when you
actually compare the isoforms that are
being detected by one method and another
and well here you have just to to to
notice is that red means that the
overlap between two uh analysis
pipelines on the same data of the on the
same sample here we are comparing also
different type of uh sequencing methods
and library preparation so when we have
read the
overlap is very low and when you have
blue the overlap is high so you can see
a lot of red here so in general there is
a very little
agreement in general
and actually for example when you see uh
which is then uh so the consistency of
detection as a function of the uh
different uh
pipelines right so here we are comparing
again different tools different library
preparation etc so what we see is that
the great maturity and the great
majority of the transcripts are actually
uh detected only by one submission
only by one submission right
and the overlap by everybody is very
little and then we have a range in
between right so those transcripts of
those transcripts that are detected by a
few number of pipelines
tend to be uh enriched in the novel
categories so like the novel not in
catalog and complete space matches the
annoying catalog you can see and as
there is more agreement we have an an
enrichment of the full displacements
that are kind of the transcript that are
in the reference
okay so this is giving you an idea of
how difficult this is and actually this
is for example
one uh one of the of the genes that we
have uh uh in this uh in this results
right so this is the gfbdh gene in the
sample
wtc11 and here you have the alignment of
the transcript models we i'm not talking
about reads here right i'm just talking
about the predictions that
different pipelines did on different on
on different library preparations and
analysis platform on the same sample
okay this is the gene code annotation
right
and this is the diversity that we got
back
right you can see that some places is
kind of a better result and some others
we have this huge diversity of
predictions
[Music]
so for me
actually one of the big upcoming
challenges in the long-range rna is to
identify
uh which of the detected transcripts
does keep models are real
words to annotate also it's important
and how to describe this complexity and
well ali was
we said
triplex of simplex way of doing i don't
know if it's so simplex but uh it's it's
a contribution i think it's very
important that we have to start thinking
how we describe this
okay
so um i think one of the important
things is how we uh identify what is the
true novelty what is the not true
novelty so i think this is one of the
big questions that
everybody all the tools have tried to
resolve
uh we have tried to to to create some
simulation tools uh in order to to
assess this a little bit this is work in
progress it's not perfect but i'm
mentioning this in case and if you want
to to use it so we have now a scanty sim
basically what we do here is to fake the
novelty in a controlled way so we take
the your ttf with simulator which with
all transcripts that are in your gtf but
then we
evaluate how the transcripts are related
to each other and we remove a number of
them in such a way that we have a
reduced reference and when you predict
the transcript models these ones that
you eliminated results to be a full
splice match what they are in the
reference but they are also in complete
displacements normally in catalog
phenomena in catalog and we know that so
we can assess
the ability that the tool has to detect
these types of novelties
and just uh some examples of different
tools what we see in general and here
these are kind of previous versions of
many of these tools so i will not say
that this is exactly how they are
working now but what we see is that in
general for the known right so this will
be the red right
the known uh transcripts the sensitivity
the sensitivity and prediction in
general i tend to be higher than for the
novels right and there are some tools
that are doing better with the novels
but in general this is what you will
find right so uh
um so we we still have a big issue and a
big work to do in trying to uh to
characterize this novelty and identify
the one that is correct
uh one of the things that we do because
uh scandi allows you is to use
orthogonal data in case it's necessary
and for example we know that we will
look at the fullest place matches which
are those that have uh good junctions
and they are close to the uh to the ends
of the reference truss people have the
atheists of the the dts but if we look
at the dss most of them will have cage
support for the full express matches
that is what we expect but actually
there is also a fraction of incompletes
right that will have that in most cases
you don't have cage support right also
expected but there is actually yes and
there is a number of them that they have
to support
and actually what we see is that
sometimes it's difficult to generate
cage data so we can actually use uh the
short the illumina reits with this tss
ratio metrics that we measure because we
have seen that there is quite an overlap
between the the the value of this ratio
and the cage support right so when you
have support for cage you will have
higher ratios and actually what we see
is that these higher ratios are
supportive of the fullest place matches
and the reference matches not that much
of the incomplete displays much as
expected but we can identify some of
them in which this kind of
support is similar so we can do that we
can use that also to try to create
the transcript models so at the end of
the day what we are doing now in this
county is to use the the quality control
of scanty to characterize the
transcriptome when we have external data
we introduce that and then we
characterize we characterize the
properties of the transcript and
actually we are we have
we use what is scanty filter i'm not
going to be explaining exactly how this
works in the paper um in the previous
paper but this filter would
discard and those transcripts that i
have not enough support in some cases
what we find is that by doing that we
lose genes and we know that the gene is
expressed because we have evidence of
transcripts so that we have implemented
a rescue strategy so that we can come
and we can get this back
and actually when we have this
rescue approach we can use a machine
learning approach or just a
rules what we find is that our uh
sensitivity and precision uh increases
uh in detecting
the transcript models and dynamic
okay so that was what we are doing and
trying to characterize uh uh the
complexity and identifying uh the the
transcript models that we can kind of
believe
but of course i mentioned that i am very
much interested in in in function and
annotation okay so i will explain a
little bit about these other tools
the iso anode tools is a method in which
we are trying to predict a lot of
different functional labels for these
nodal transcript models of the ones that
are annotated and it's a complex
algorithm in which basically we are
predicting the noble motives both at the
rna level and also at the protein level
and here we can have things like
obstructing regulatory elements
we predict also we we map actually uh
microrna binding sites of rna binding
proteins binding sites and at the
protein level we have pretty much
you know domains
ptms nucleus localization signals that
you make
uh applying these different data sets we
have been able to to annotate with
different uh type of labels
quite a person what what what a number
of the transcripts that are all either
in the reference or in different
language data sets so we are achieving
high coverage
and probably one of the most interesting
things to look is that when once you
have this information is like is this
really relevant i mean it's it's really
uh these different types of from giving
you a a different functional load and
this is what this graph is indicating so
the way to read this is here we have
different kind of uh features that are
notated at the transcript level at the
protein level the length of the bar
indicates how many of the genes with
multiple isoforms have uh have an
annotation here for example
i could say for example that uh here
these are the uh uh the uterine right
right of the three utrs which are
annotated for most of the transits right
and and and then in the in the darker
color is where we have information of of
the isoforms of these genes how many
have differences at the ut are in terms
of length and you can see that we have a
lot quite a lot of numbers at
quite a high percentage both at the uh
five to five
five utr and three parameter but
probably also the protein level is
interesting to look at this for example
for pfm domains we have like predictions
for 70 of the genes and more than half
of them have different contents in the
in the protein domain right
and this is what we use then in the
tapas framework so basically the idea of
tapas is what is a tool in which you can
uh
kind of say user friendly way to analyze
this data visualize this data and make a
comparisons between samples and
basically what we have is that we start
with the gene models
that are created by the long-range
technologies the functional annotation
provided by iso analyst and some some
sort of quantification right and now we
are quantifying with short reads but in
case that said the low reach uh
quantification is is reliable you can
use that too
uh we analyze uh a lot of different
things here so the potential of the
potential as i mentioned before of these
transit models to have differences in
functional content but also things like
differential isoform usage whether you
have switching whether you have one
major isoforms with relations in
relationship with the rest
and uh also importantly what was very
interesting for us is that we also can
because we have this information of the
functional elements we can start at his
question of which are the functional
domains and the functional sites that
are changing because of alternative
splicing right we can do that for
domains but we can also do that for
example to look at
the
utrs we can identify if there are
functional domains that are called
supplies of are modularly exclusive so
we can also you know do this kind of
questions sorry
so this is data sets that i'm going to
be using to illustrate some of the
things that
tapas does and this was a neural
differentiation time course uh starting
for uh neuroprogenitor cells in mouse
and we differentiate them to
oligodendrocytes in and modern neurons
and i'm going to be using some of these
data that we sequence with pac bio and
illumina
so one of the things for example that we
can we can evaluate here is the
differences between differential gene
expression and difference and
differential iso form usage and actually
the amount of these differential
exoplanet usage
and i think liar mentioned that
yesterday that we have a number quite a
number of of genes in which the
differences in gene expressions or the
local change of the gene is nearly zero
however the usage of the isoform is huge
so there is a strong regulation
by alternative splicing this is
something that we know but then we can
look at which are the functions that are
involved in those genes that are mostly
regulated by differential gene
expression or mostly regulated by
differential isotherm usage and you can
see
here in red will be different
different um
processes and red are the the the
relative contributions of differential
gene expression and in blue is
differential isophone usage what you can
see here is that this is a shared
process so it's the contribution of both
and actually by differential gene
expression you have most of the
regulation and these tankers but there
are particular functions like for
example here brain development of myelin
things that are mostly regulated by the
differential inclusion of isopods
we can also identify then okay which are
the functional domains that actually
change more right not only are present
but also change more and here you have
we have also different uh tests in which
we can see for example the disorder
domains
the the disorder the disorder regions of
pipham domains and the microarranged
binding sites tend to be mostly changing
between the isoforms that are
differentially expressed
and actually if you if you look at the
functional content of the isoforms that
are mostly expressed and then these
neural progenitor cells often only go
dendrocytes what we find is that in
general for the different type of
functional elements
though
the isoform that is chosen to be
expressed in the in the mature uh
oligodendrocytes have a higher
functional content so the the choice is
to increase functionality of the
isoforms that are being expressed
this is an example that we validated is
the category in delta one uh this is
differentially spliced is not
differentially expressed but this
differentially supplies between
progenitors and oligodendrocytes you can
see here the strong switch right
uh we identified that this switch was
associated to the differential inclusion
of a nuclear localization signal okay
that was predicted to be uh
included in oleodendrocyte but not in
the progenitors and then when we were
analyzing the nuclear function that's
exactly what we found at this
differential inclusion of this protein
there so these predictions can also give
you some
testable hypotheses of differential
functionality and i think
by um
this is another example of another uh
another gene and this is the mul1
protein we predicted that there was a
differential inclusion of a binding
domain and this binding domain was
actually
included in the motor neurons
and then what we know is that mole 1 is
involved actually in
the regulation of the mitochondria and
somehow is involved in uh the balance
between fusion and fission in in
mitochondria and by uh the differential
inclusion of this protein uh
we
our hypothesis was that this was
controlling the balance
between the uh
the fusions of mitochondria and the
fission of them that are contributing to
the regulation of the uh
of the energy balance
and it's this these are the kind of
things that you can start looking at and
and and asking when you combine the low
reads with the functional annotation and
the differential expression
i had here uh
some other stories about the utr so we
are also looking at how the differential
inclusion of utrs contributes to
regulation by micrornas and we find many
of them involved in neurogenesis that
are differentially included as the
the the cells progresses towards
differentiation and i want some of these
results
i also have a single cell story but i
think that i'm running out of time so if
you want i can share with you these
results later
but
basically for me the concluding remark
is that the third generation sequencing
technologies are really great but um
because they they they are really
magnification lens in the study of the
transcriptome but also there are
important challenges which are the
identification of the true transcriptome
the description and annotation of the
complexity and also the understanding of
what that complexity actually means
and thank you for your attention
[Music]
and the acknowledgement sir that's right
all right question serrano
thanks and a great talk and i apologize
if you mentioned this already but i'm
wondering what fraction of the
null isoforms are coming from regions of
the genome that are not even genes like
not known genes is that something you
have looked at
but that depends on the organism right
so
normally
so we we
different pipelines for the analysis of
of the lord's data used to report small
number of intergenic transcripting human
amounts for example
and most of the times after we filter
the data with this county we we get rid
of them because they are they are not
well supported so really
the amount of uh novel
genes that we kind of validate is
relatively small in human and mouse
when we did the manatee of course there
we were more right so it depends on the
organism
thanks
so sorry um you have identical twins
with last name
yeah uh yeah sorry no
i could not quickly find
the teacher
and then i put
alessandra and then i forgot to teach
you anyway so
no i this is not a it's not the question
for you specifically it's for you for
ali for uh for hugging for new york so
you show here for instance that you find
evidence of uh
alternative spice forms with different
protein functions but i guess that you
are aware of this war by michael dress
yeah
claiming that actually
there is only one protein also for uh by
albus plasma as well
that there is only essentially one i
support virginia and all this
alternative spicing is totally
i guess
i get this question in every single talk
every single time i give what is the
answer the answer is that the truth is
in between the two kind of
the two worlds
so for example when we we use tapas for
the analysis normally we only focus on
very strong
changes and we remove everything that is
slowly expressed i believe that a lot of
these lowly expressed iso forms probably
they are not making it to a protein
but
we have found
evidence in many cases for example by by
looking at a localization of proteins
of uh yeah the different isoforms that
we predicted
and
we have
collaborated with the different people
that find this uh this
these major isoforms when they are for
example when they are expressed or they
are the
the most expressed isoform in a
different tissue of a different cell
type
in those cases we have been able to
identify a few right but i agree that
there is a lot of these uh
transcriptional complexity that does not
translate into different proteins
but they do exist and i think it's worse
to study them
so the brain tissue has the biggest
complexity in splicing have you been
able to track down that regulation to
some rna binding proteins or some
specific mechanisms
so
we annotate
rna binding proteins binding sites right
and
and with iso or not
and we have found
that
in a number of cases it's not always
right but in a number of cases that
uh the differential iso from expressions
is associated to an enrichment of a
particular
uh uh rna binding proteins for example
muscle blind is one of them that we have
found uh regularly one of the things
that is important here to to realize is
that we are kind of collecting uh
functional information and and
projecting that on our transcript models
and i think this is very much biased by
the amount of information that you have
about
in this case for example rna binding
protein so uh there are a number of
splicing factors that are well studied
and then the you know the binding sites
are well known and then we collect them
and then probably we are also detecting
them because of that
but in some cases yes i think that
um although we have been able to find
some kind of um
functional elements that you know are
kind of rich
and differentially in splicing
in general what we find is that the way
in which you know uh
differential isoform expression
uh results in a different protein and of
a potential different protein and the
functional domains that are included
is very diverse and i think it's more
important which is the function
that is being regulated
uh that actually whether at the end the
regulation is because you uh skip a
functional domain of uh
uh post-translational modification for
example right
yes so i was going to ask you something
that that's actually been on my mind
quite a bit which is
do you see categories of genes
that heavily use alternate splicing and
others that don't
and in a sense we keep on being in
between okay maybe
the average gene has five i isoforms but
i don't think that's the case it's
either you have 100
or and there's a ton of genes that only
have two or one
and so have you like tried with these
functional adaptations to sort of also
characterize the ones that also show
very little evidence of splicing at all
and see whether it is functional sets of
genes like say transcription factors as
a group get less spliced
than
receptors
to try to see whether
splicing is more important for some
functions of the cells than others
yeah that's a very good question we
actually
we have
figured about this in the scanty paper
and
there what we found
was surprisingly for us
that
very surprisingly for us that um
carbon metabolism was heavily
uh
well it's not that it had a lot of
isoforms okay so there what we analyzed
is that we found a lot of novel isoforms
and and so
things like everything that was related
to metabolic processes
and neural processes were those type of
functions that popped up as uh
having a lot of novelty in our analysis
now that was 2018
and i have not repeated discussion this
kind of analysis and a lot of in you
know in what we know on how to process
the data uh has changed
but um
so
i'm not sure if this this result will
hold today but that's what we found
there because we look into that and
yeah and surprise and i think that there
was also uh uh
probably a reason for that is because
these i mean uh
metabolic genes are highly expressed
right
so somehow the chance of having a more
different isoforms is is greater there
while the
neurological processes related
genes were highly expressed in europe i
mean in our system right so yeah
but uh yeah that's a great question
yeah
so so i i wonder whether you have um
compared the list to
the list from from the illuminating the
draggable genome
yeah he led this project where we also
contributed
we looked at the human
proteome and and drug targets and
clinical trial proteins and study
proteins and then
once or
so
but it would be interesting to
to take that list
and compare
yeah well i haven't done that
but yeah that could be an interesting
comparison it's also hard to tell
whether it's good or bad for a drug drug
target to be alternative disguise right
because it
it could be good if you only want to
block one of them
well thanks let's think both of the
speakers
everyone out onto the patio we have a
poster session and a reception now for
the next hour